our serious issues that matter this
morning takes a closer look at America's
longest war we are approaching the 17th
year of the conflict in Afghanistan it
was launched on October 7th 2001 in
response to the September 11th attacks
defense secretary Jim mattis told a
Senate committee last month the United
States is not winning the war the
trohman the Trump administration is
reviewing its policy on Afghanistan in
comments last week President Trump said
quote I want to find out why we were
been there for 17 years
joining us now to talk about the
challenges Michele Flournoy she served
as Undersecretary of defense for policy
under President Obama from 2009 to 2012
she is a co-founder and CEO of the
Center for a new American security
Michelle good morning good morning why
are we still in Vietnam I'm still in
Afghanistan you know I think first of
all the Taliban has proven a very
resilient insurgency they have support
from Pakistan they have support from
outside countries we've had an Afghan
government that has been very weak and
and and really plagued by corruption and
we too have made mistakes between 2003
and 2009 remember all of the attention
and the resources in the leadership
focused a switch to focus on Iraq and we
sort of kept Afghanistan as a backfill
when we invaded Iraq would put the seeds
of a continued stay and perhaps losing
Afghanistan yes and then when we when
President Obama came in and launched the
surge in 2009 that was important to
regaining momentum but he also announced
that that surge would only last a short
while but less than two years and so the
Taliban had the signal you know we can
just wait this out so is anybody winning
here do you think and is there a clear
end game it's it's really a stalemate at
this point the good news is that the
Afghan forces are in the lead and with
our support they continue to to hold
their own but they do need our continued
support I think we need to reinforce
them with additional enabling
capabilities like intelligence and fire
support and close air support and so
forth but the real issue here is a
political strategy how do we use that
leverage of additional troops of
supporting the Afghans to actually get
the Taliban to the negotiating table No
it's gonna win this on the battlefield
it has to get to some kind of negotiated
yeah we're doing this series because
Afghanistan may not be on the front page
but this really matters first of all how
much territory does the Taliban control
now compared to 9/11 it controls more
now than it did when when we first
started the war Taliban controls more
territory so yes so it is there's
definitely been a backslide but what you
see is an Afghan military that is
stepping up that is in the lead and that
continues to improve with our help the
headlines this morning and some of the
reporting at CBS News is Russia now
rearming the Taliban so what we have
evidence that Russia is providing small
arms to the Taliban also Iran and so we
have this problem of outside support the
irony of that is that we support the
Mujahideen who are trying to kick Russia
out of Afghanistan yours a guide right
and so I think both all of the outside
powers are hedging their bets they're
trying to be friendly with the Taliban
in case the Taliban wins it's also a
great opportunity to poke the United
States in the eye so what should we be
doing that we're not doing so I thought
what I think you we want to see that
coming out of the Trump administration
is a very clear statement of commitment
look we have to remember why are we
there we are there because we don't want
Afghanistan to once again become a safe
haven for terrorists that could strike
the United States it could be the return
of al Qaeda but now it could also be the
coming of the Islamic state who's
already been probing in Afghanistan to
see if they can find some some ground
the last thing we want is that is Isis
to pick up and move from Syria to
Afghanistan because we're not pushing
back hard of this issue is on Trump's
desk right now yes sitting before him is
a recommendation from the defense
secretary James Madison increase the
number of troops in Afghanistan what
will he do well I think did he do I I
say there's a big debate inside the
White House between those who don't want
him to touch this and who want to get us
out of Afghanistan and those who believe
that we've got to double down support
the Afghans I think the most important
thing beyond the troop numbers is a
political strategy you have to have a
broader strategy into which the military
portion fits you have to have a
to get the Taliban to the table nobody's
gonna win this little bag this is the
state it is said that McMasters and
matters have influence with the present
especially matters what does he want I
think he wants more troops and a
political strategy that leverages those
troops to get to some kind of [ __ ]
where are the Iranians who have not
looked to in favor on the Taliban never
considered the Taliban enemies I think
that Iranians are sort of playing both
sides they support aspects of the
government they support aspects of the
Taliban and they're waiting to see what
happens you spent several years in the
Obama administration what do you think
the Trump administration could learn
from what you learned at the time that
you were there I think the biggest
lesson is and are you talking to them
Michelle well you know I we I always
send them what we write and say but who
knows if that's read but I think the
most important thing is the US has to
signal a long-term commitment to
Afghanistan as a partner for fighting
terrorism in the region if there's any
waffling any sense that we're not fully
committed the Taliban will continue to
wait us out and the partners in the
region won't take the necessary risks to
pressure the Taliban to come to the
table the Trump administration has also
turned to the Blackwater CEO Eric Prince
about a private army a mercenary army
how would that work not very well
I think contractors can do very
important missions base support
logistics and so forth but we saw in
Iraq what happens when you rely on them
too extensively huge problems with
Blackwater massacring Iraqi civilians in
a firefight in the middle of the city we
don't want to go there again the truth
is the US military is an advisory
mission that they can do best they can
use support from contractors and limited
areas but it's no substitute for putting
in the troops we need to support the I
think it's good that you were here to
remind people why we were there in the
first place because I think it's been so
long many people have forgotten yeah the
original intent and that return of a
safe haven unfortunately could happen
and so we have to keep the pressure on
the terrorist groups in that region just
aside I go to a lot of conferences where
they talk about Nash security policy one
of the people they really listen to it's
Michele Flournoy
thank you
thank you very much thank you for being
here